good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this intelligence squared
debate on the motion Kal Marx was right
capitalism post 2008 is falling apart
under the weight of its own
contradictions since the collapse of the
Western banking system in 2007 to 2009
the advanced industrial economies have
struggled to recover in spite of highly
unorthodox measures huge monetary
stimulus and yet the constraints of high
public debt and anemic growth have
proved as yet almost insurmountable is
this an illustration of the inherent
contradictions of capitalism the
immiseration of the proletariat the rate
of the profit the tendency of the rate
of profit to fall or are we instead
seeing some exceptional event brought
about not by the contradictions of
capitalism but by the failure of one
particular segment of the economy the
financial system and at the same time
seeing the productive power of the
market in other parts of the world
notably China as you came into the hall
you will have been asked your initial
view after hearing the speeches from our
distinguished panel you will be asked to
vote on the motion in front of you you
have a ticket with for or against when
it comes to the votes you'll have a
ballot box passed along the rows in
front of you if you wish to vote for the
motion you put the side of it with four
in the box against but against in the
box if you are undecided please put the
whole voting card into the box the
motion the proponents of the motion will
speak first motion again Karl Marx was
right capitalism post 2008 is falling
apart under the weight of its own
contradictions the speaker who's going
to introduce that motion is Tristan
hunt historian Labour MP and author of a
biography of Friedrich Engels
please welcome Tristram hunt
Tristram your time startsnow Oliver
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
in July 1851 friedrich engels the
manchester cotton lord and co-author of
the manifesto of the communist party
wrote to his friend Karl Marx in London
with some very promising news
speculation railways is again reaching
dazzling Heights since the first of
January most shares have risen by 40%
and the worst ones more than any this is
promising
clearly capitalism's then knew more was
just around the corner
the East India market was overstocked
while the British cloth industry was
being hit hard by a flood of cheap
cotton inputs if the crash in the market
coincides with such a gigantic crop
things will be cheery indeed Peter
ermine his business partner is already
fouling his breeches at the very thought
of it and the little tree frog is a
pretty good barometer bankruptcies were
picking up in London and Liverpool
overproduction was glut in the market
and Engels was adamant that the end of
capitalism was nigh instead it wasn't to
be exports urged wages rose standards of
living improved and the mid Victorian
boom ground inexplicably on in 1857
Angles optimism returned as the markets
faltered the American crashes
superheroes and not yet over by a long
chalk now we have a chance the
conditions for revolution were once
again right with a capitalist mode of
production and collapse the working
class would surely rise to the occasion
but two months into the crash the
proletariat had still yet to realize its
historic calling there are as yet few
signs of revolution angles noted
gloomily for the long period of
prosperity has been fearfully
demoralizing so you will appreciate
friends that there is something of a
prehistory to this evening's debate
indeed my old friends Marx and Engels
have been predicting the end of
capitalism for over 150 years and now
our opponents are suggesting that the
immediate failure of such predictions
invalidates our claim that
Karl Marx is right and we would suggest
quite the country to argue this in the
wake of cash machines crashing in Cyprus
over sixty billion pounds spent on
bailing out British banks and the
repercussions of the global financial
crash still making their way through
eviscerated social fabric of so many
Western societies well I put it to you
it is positively perverse as Terry
Eagleton has written in the light of the
continuing global financial crisis to
claim that Marxism was finished was
rather like claiming that firefighting
was out of date because arsonists were
growing more crafty and resourceful than
ever I would like to suggest you that
Marx has rarely seemed more relevant
Marxist top researchers on 150-year tip
was how the New York Times the New York
Times
marked 150th anniversary of the
publication of the communist manifesto a
text which more than any other as they
put it recognized the unstoppable wealth
creating power of capitalism predicted
it would conquer the world and warned
that this inevitable globalization of
national economies and cultures would
have divisive and painful consequences
and the times was right ladies gentleman
Karl Marx and Friedrich Engels were the
first to chart the uncompromising
unrelenting compulsively iconoclastic
nature of capitalism it is pitilessly
torn asunder the motley feudal ties that
bound man to his natural superiors and
is left remaining no other nexus between
man and man their naked self interests
then callous cash payments it has
drowned the most heavenly ecstasy's of
religious fervor of chivalrous
enthusiasm of Philistine sentimentalism
in the icy water of egotistical
calculation and it was Marx who revealed
how capitalism would crush languages
cultures traditions even nations in its
wake in one word it creates a world
after its own image he wrote long before
globalization became a byword for
Americanized
and marks was also clear about the
social consequences the growing
divisions between the lifestyles of the
rich and the poor under unregulated
capitalism what Benjamin Disraeli and Ed
Miliband would call the two nations and
in Britain we have seen this problem
with the emergence of the so called
squeeze middle and the diagnosis is
right our current models of capitalism
are not working the wealth generated by
the growth prior to 2008 simply did not
trickle down to ordinary people living
standards began to stagnate from as
early as 2003 and won't even return to
that until well after 2015 and as for
the growing extremes at the top and the
bottom we'll just take a look at last
week's fascinating great British class
survey with its account of the precariat
an update of Marx and Engels is
proletariat and the elite as Professor
Mike savage of the London School of
Economics puts it it is striking that
we've been able to discern a distinctive
elite whose sheer economic advantage
sets it apart from the other classes at
the opposite extreme
we have discerned the existence of a
sizable group which is marked by the
lack of any significant amount of
economic cultural or social capital
these are the two nations the
recognition of the existence of this
group along with the elite is a powerful
reminder that our conventional
approaches to class have hindered our
recognition of these two extremes which
occupy a distinctive place in British
society who can tell us now that Karl
Marx was wrong so let us get to the crux
of the matter the 2008 crash and it's
lingering aftermath revealed the failure
of the theology of the uncontrolled
global free market that is what we're
arguing about that is what capitalism is
about and all Marx and Engels is warning
over the dangers of manat
capitalism and concentrated finance have
come to pass so why then no total
collapse of capitalism because right
around the world governments have been
forced to bail out the so-called free
market we've bailed out the banks we
have subsidized industries we sorted out
the insurance sector we've underpinned
financial services we've kept the whole
system afloat from car scrappage schemes
to AIG to nationalizing Fannie and
Freddie Mae it is the forces of
collectivism which have saved capitalism
the level of public support the extent
of state involvement how we all in this
room bear the heavy burden of H+ Lloyd's
RBS and Northern Rock how we have
taxpayers underwrite every major
transaction now across the City of
London how moral hazard has effectively
been liquidated in the contemporary
economy the very continuance of
capitalism under current conditions is
proof that Karl Marx was right
capitalism has once again crumbled under
the weight of its own internal
contradictions and it is the state in
America in Cyprus in China in India in
the UK which is once again saved it the
facade of normality is vindication of
the crisis and why you can have no
hesitation in supporting this motion
tonight
although I do fear that Marx and Engels
rather than being delighted with the
current turn of events are themselves
probably feeling fearfully demoralized
thank
Thank You Tristram and our first speaker
against the motion is George Magnus
George is an economist commentator and
author he has a long record as an
economist in the financial services
industry most recently as chief
economist and senior economic advisor at
UBS for 15 years till recently he now
works as an independent consultant
George your time starts now
Thank You Oliver and good evening ladies
and gentlemen in the wilds of North
London where I live near Highgate
Cemetery is a grave and a tombstone of
the wily old political economist who's
the subject of tonight's debate many of
you may have been there to pay homage or
simply to visit and reflect
but the revival of interest in car marks
since the financial crisis and the
reason he's here in spirit this evening
is because we're suffering as I'm sure
you know an attack of deep economic
pessimism you'll also know very well
that our fixation with this pessimism
and crisis and capitalism is not unique
for example John Maynard Keynes wrote
about this in 1930 in a tract called the
economic consequences for our
grandchildren in which he said it is
common to hear people say that the epoch
of enormous economic progress is over
and that a decline in prosperity is more
likely than an improvement in the decade
ahead of us eerily familiar words but my
view is that Keynes's dismissal of the
pessimism of his own time has relevance
today and I'd like to argue two points
first that the whole point about the
contradictions of capitalism is not
specifically whether Marx is or Marx's
analysis is relevant which personally I
think in many ways it is but it's the
outcome it's the synthesis and our
capacity to basically nurture and
establish coping mechanisms and the
second point is that the main threats to
our economic and social model today
come actually from two sources that
didn't even exist until quite recently
and are neither the direct outcome of
capitalism nor terminal so the first
point on Marx's tombstone as you'll know
if you've been there there's an
inscription taken from the theses on
Feuerbach
which says the philosophers have only
interpreted the world in various ways
the point however is to change it which
is precisely what our antecedents have
done by developing coping mechanisms
like institutions of the rule of law
limited liability companies trades union
mutual societies insurance welfare and
technological discoveries that drive
productivity income and jobs finding
those coping mechanisms is an endless
task and we need to make more progress
on at least three of them the first is
that we can't obviously keep shifting
income from the owners of labor to the
owners of capital without experiencing
income inequality impoverishment of
workers relatively if not absolutely
excess capacity and unemployment the
stronger investment that we had in the
1990s and the 2000s has of course given
way to a bust real wages have been
stagnant or declining in this country
the median real wage has fallen by about
9% since 2009 back to levels last seen
in 2003 and the labor compensation share
of national income has fallen profit
share has risen by about five to ten
percentage points in most rich countries
the second point is that finance or
second contradiction if you what is that
finance has been an enabler of
innovation and growth but as articulated
plently by the economists Hyman Minsky
thirty years ago it's also an in dead in
dodging a source of systemic instability
I'm sure this doesn't need to go into
any further explanation here except to
say that as the raconteur and economist
and diplomat JK Galbraith once quipped
about recurring bouts of speculation and
euphoria from Rome onwards every
generation basically suffers from a
Bravo T of financial memory and every
generation makes the specious
association between the ownership of
money and the possession of intelligence
bankers pay and the wider issue of
management ryu narrating remuneration of
course are rarely out of the headlines
and an obvious grappling iron for
capitalism's critics but the problem is
that rent gouging or rent seeking as
it's more politely known is the result
of eminently fixable market and
corporate governance flaws we could for
example break up the banks as the
Vickers Commission has urged we could
ban or restrict the use of stock options
and other tools that tie remuneration to
short-term stock market performance
there's nothing specifically systemic
about not being able to fix these
problems if we really want the third
point I've just quickly mentioned is the
need to cope better with globalization
capitalism's propensity to globalize has
generally been a force for the good I'd
submit but the blowback in the form of
the growing economic significance of
China and other major emerging markets
is a big problem integrating in their
own ways Western capitalism's best
practices from markets to modernity and
from meritocracy to the rule of law
these countries are no longer just
consumers of Western capitalism's goods
and services and in some respects clones
but also very powerful competitors and
rivals big big contradiction issues
without a doubt but my point is that
even if our existing political leaders
suffer from up from myopia and something
that I like to call deficit attention
disorder thank you
the capitalist
the capitalist model has been and
remains adaptable now the two points I
mentioned earlier which are relatively
recent are 21st century aging and
technology which actually have in some
respects the flimsiest flimsiest of
links to capitalism and our questionably
though big issues for example in the
first case weak fertility and rising
life expectancy are driving a unique and
relentless rise in the age structure of
our societies never seen before and it's
challenging us to redefine the social
rights and obligations of citizens
versus the state it's a very complex
issue to get over particularly at a time
like this
and the thing about technology in
automation is that they are also
displacing white-collar including
skilled jobs from retail to radiology
and from clerical to even legal
positions and I think this explains
partly the predominance of low-income
part-time jobs in countries that Eaton
have raised employment since 2009 modern
technology is equally an issue for
emerging countries for example in China
the Taiwanese company Foxconn who has
you know manufacture for Apple Sony and
lots of others in China has started to
substitute robots for workers their plan
is to substitute 1 million by 2015
automation and robots are generating
very strong demand for labor at the top
of the occupational structure and the
bottom leaving as my opponent Tristram
said before those with average levels of
human capital and skill in the middle
very vulnerable and dragging income
inequality higher we don't really know
how we're going to solve this problem in
the long run but capitalism still has
very persuasive credentials let me give
you two little anecdotes first Henry
Ford and a prominent labor leader
supposedly once teased each other about
factory robots not being able to pay
union dues or buy motor cars Henry just
simply retorted though that he was going
to pay his workers twice the going rate
which he did which underscores a process
in capitalism that runs from
productivity to higher wages and lower
prices rising demand and jobs and so on
there's also a story about Milton
Friedman visiting a Chinese construct
project and asking his host why workers
were using so many shovels and so few
machines told that this was a job
creation project Friedman said in that
case why don't you give them spoons the
point of course is that capital
including human capital makes people
more productive and societies better off
and my hunch is that in time the
revolution going on in advanced
manufacturing in energy sector and new
technology will deliver significant
benefits so in conclusion mr. chairman
our opponents may argue that capitalism
itself is the systemic problem behind
our pessimism and that markets don't
work that a radical redrawing of the
boundaries between the state and the
private sector is necessary personally I
don't think anyone thinks that Lace a
fair is the answer but we should be
careful what we wish for the influential
Chinese magazine Kushina warned the
country's leaders recently that the
heavy stand of the heavy hand of the
state was stifling competition
distorting resource allocation and
encouraging corruption and red seeking
and social fragmentation China's leaders
have the courage and will to implement
difficult reforms in the next five to
ten years Chinese capitalism will move
our way if they don't we shall see
ladies and gentlemen finally our
predicament I would submit is not the
sound of capitalists and falling apart
but a painful period of adjustment from
one economic and technological period to
another thank
thank you George our second speaker for
the motion is Robin Blackburn Robin is
leaving furlough at the University of
Essex
he's a former editor of the new left
review where he's written on the
collapse of Soviet Communism and the
credit crunch of 2008 Robin your time
starts now
thank you yes Marx was right if you
study our motion you'll see that where
we aren't arguing he was right about
everything simply about the
contradictions of capitalism
what did Marx mean by contradictions
let's look at some examples Marx urged
that capitalism by generating wealth
that one pole and poverty at another
destroyed its own momentum those who are
badly paid or unemployed couldn't be
good customers in recent decades growing
inequality undermined accumulation but
the financial wizards had a fix wall
street in the city having failed to
nourish their own domestic economies
instead came up with a brilliant idea of
becoming loan sharks lending to the poor
at high interest rates and then bundling
these debts into supposedly failsafe
financial products but extravagant
inequalities eventually took their toll
US subprime borrowers the poor devoted
defaulted in droves while tens of
millions of underpaid Chinese workers
couldn't buy much from the West or
anyone else these hard facts punctured
the Delirium of investors pulled the rug
from underneath the big banks and
brought on the global downturn but
here's the good news
working people in China have protested
at miserable pay recent worker militancy
in China has raised wages which had be
good for global recovery if only the
other governments were doing the heavy
lifting to boost global demand but
there's no sign of concerted measures of
debt forgiveness
public investment to reignite growth
this leads us to another contradiction
namely even as the different parts of
the capitalist world become more
interdependent
they each resort to begun my neighbor
policies the IMF and World Bank should
boost lending to producers but instead
they tolerate competitive austerity and
urge all countries to strive for an
export surplus as if this wasn't a
mathematical impossibility it would be
more rational to lend money to the man
in the moon and then let him purchase
any unsold inventory that might sound
ridiculous but scarcely less so than the
world of QE or quantitative easing
now practiced by the world's most
powerful central banks QE sounds a
little queasy a coded reference to
financial bowel movements but it's
nearly really no more than printing
money and then putting it the way of
banking folk next item in the repertoire
of desperate expedience is helicopter
cash as the financial explained times
explained last Friday this involves I
kid you not simply sharing the
population with great wads of notes as
if dropped from helicopters but somehow
the giveaways all land on the financial
districts if the financial authorities
had the courage of their convictions
they instead pay out fifty thousand
pounds to every citizen with the proviso
that they must pay down debt or spend
the money this would really get the
economy moving but we all know it won't
happen it's too sensible so here's
another perversity of capitalism it's
official custodians resort to give away
as far bigger and far less justified
than the welfare states they demonize
official bailouts represent socialism
for bankers welfare for billionaires
down on their luck I should reiterate
once again
didn't get everything right the workers
haven't revolted in the way he thought
likely he didn't anticipate global
warming or the world wide web or reality
TV and he was probably wrong about the
declining rate of profit but he did
wrestle with the madcap logic of what he
called fictitious capital there'll be
some here tonight who've heard enough
nice things about Margaret Thatcher in
the last 24 hours to last them a
lifetime forgive me
therefore for pointing out that wild
Karl Marx and Margaret Thatcher differed
about almost everything they agreed on
the importance of capitalism many
founders of economics and social science
analyzed the dynamic of industrial
society or commercial Society or
modernity Marx coined this concept of a
capitalist mode of production
he saw capital accumulation as the
juggernaut of the age a 19th century
thinker Marx saw rampant capitalism
leading to a world of pervasive and
unstable commodification this was a
world in which everything must be for
sale and have its price a world in which
everyone has to become a two-leg profit
and loss center and everyone is urged to
take on debt to buy exotic insurance
products and to do their duty as
insatiable consumers on Saturdays Radio
4's radio for money box someone
explained that enterprising banks have
persuaded customers to insure against
automobile theft even when they don't
actually own a car
marx held that the world of capital was
anarchic that it had no regulatory
center notwithstanding the IMF and World
Bank this is still true when it comes to
bailouts the international organizations
only have the resources that rich
countries allow them to have they don't
have a fiscal base of their own the
uncovered world of international money
is constantly prone to speculation and
crisis because crisis is its only way of
wiping slates clean and starting afresh
and money is sovereign because the
world's great powers allow themselves to
be pushed around by Bermuda and the
Cayman Islands or perhaps something else
is going on maybe it's some other
organizations who are pushing us all
around the United States with its
boundless faith in capitalism is also
the country why in October 2008 the
Treasury secretary opted to take out
huge tanks stakes in the big banks the
US administration also nationalized to
global Titans General Motors and AIG
though they didn't go nearly far enough
these measures worth for a time quite
effective indeed in a contradiction Marx
would have pounced on the more
successful types of capitalism borrow
great doses of state intervention
coordination and public entrepreneurship
it's the laggards and dunces who parrot
the witless slogan that governments
can't pick winners in Taiwan with its
hugely successful science parks or
Brazil with its world-beating
agricultural exports they laugh at such
idiocy and then think of Communist China
with its state banks doing more to
resuscitate global demand than have
Western governments the international
markets prop up our propped up by
China's Politburo there's a palpable
contradiction of capitalism this time
one that cuts both ways I agree here in
Britain successive governments have no
faith in the British people despite
their outstanding record
of innovation instead of endowing a
string of public regional funds with the
resources to get small and medium
business investing again they channel
the cash to zombie banks whose only
pathetic thought is to join their horns
D leverage and reduce exposure having
lost a bundle betting on moonshine they
now refuse to invest in real research
centers Mark's wanted to go beyond
capitalism but he didn't reject
modernity in fact the word contradiction
is borrowed from Hegel's dialectical
philosophy and as applied to capitalism
implied that there could be virtue in
the market mechanism so long as it's
rescued from the greed of capitalists
and the blinkered dogma of
neoliberalism's high priests thank
Thank You Robin our second speaker
against the motion is Madison Perry
Manson is president and founder of the
Adam Smith Institute the free market
think-tank that's in your time starts
now
okay well like many public figures who
leave a legacy either in their writings
or their deeds Karl Marx was sometimes
right and sometimes wrong
everyone is boring Edward Heath I'm
going to concentrate on some of the
things Marx was wrong about because
they're relevant to the motion and also
it's actually more fun he was wrong to
predict that history would take us to
the inevitable triumph of the
proletariat and then stop history shows
no signs of doing either Marx is also
wrong to suggest that this could happen
first in the most advanced economies as
they reach the final stage of capitalism
in fact such revolutions as took place
came in less developed countries less
developed economies such as Russia and
China it has not happened in the
advanced economies and this could be
because Marx was wrong about something
else he predicted that capitalism would
drive down wages to survival level
before its final day knew more but in
fact as economies became more advanced
both wages and living standards rose to
levels not even dreamt of in Marx's day
and this seems to have lowered somewhat
the pressure for revolutionary violence
and change Marx was also wrong about
something very much more fundamental he
was wrong about change and I don't just
mean he was wrong about the changes that
would come about more fundamentally he
was wrong about how change takes place
he took the Hegelian model of change now
to the philosopher Hegel change comes
about in staccato triangles a state of
affairs nurtures its opposite and from
the violent clash between them a new
state of affairs emerges thesis
antithesis synthesis violence
at the very core of it and hence Marx's
commitment to revolution the folly is
that Marx was a contemporary of Darwin
he'd read Darwin's Origin of Species
he actually admired Darwin's account of
the origins of human kind
he failed however to spot the
significance of Darwin's theory of
change and to incorporate it into his
own program
Darwin advanced a gradual mechanism of
change in which small differences
gradually come to dominate over time it
is evolutionary not revolutionary and
it's a much more accurate description of
how change usually happens in human
societies much more accurate than was
Hegel's account
indeed Darwin was right and Hegel was
wrong this of course means that Marx was
also wrong wrong about change and wrong
about how capitalism would develop the
point is that capitalism changes and
evolves it has been through many
transformations the capitalism that Marx
thought would collapse under its own
contradictions is not the capitalism of
today the one that the motion refers to
in the material world organisms evolve
they respond to crises and they change a
similar thing happens with our social
practices they evolve and adapt to new
circumstances capitalism has faced many
crises each time it has evolved and
changed each time a new form of
capitalism has emerged to solve the
problems its predecessor faced this is
how human beings progress we solve our
problems by adapting our practices yes
capitalism certainly faced a crisis in
2008 but is still with us and as yet on
collapsed its evolving and responding to
the changes that are needed and as
before when the dust of crisis has
settled it will be a new version of
capitalism that goes on to generate more
wealth and to expand the opportunities
open to humankind
the new version of capitalism that
emerges will have to be won somehow
manages to keep it arm's length
the politicians wanting to fix its
outcomes for political advantage greedy
bankers
can only take reckless
if politicians make it cheap for them to
do so by turning on the taps of credit
and money politicians like booms and
bubbles because they help them to win
elections and therefore office and so
capitalism must now find procedures to
limit their ability to do this those
whose greed is for power are no less
deadly than those whose greed is for
gain and both need rules to circumscribe
their scope for action I wish to make a
further point that capitalism will
survive because it is the only valid way
we found that works in practice to
create wealth and all of the
opportunities that come in its wake Marx
was wrong about another important thing
he subscribed to the Labour theory of
value he believed that the value of the
thing arises from the labor put into
producing it hence surplus value
exploitation charging people more than
the cost labor cost of producing it
exploiting the workers wrong value is
based on demand if no one wants a thing
then no matter how much labor went into
producing it it is literally valueless
it has to be demand based we all value
things differently and that is the only
reason trade takes place we trade
because we heat you value we put a
greater value on the thing that the
other person has than what we're
offering in exchange and when we trade
we both gain something more valuable
than we had it's a win-win situation and
it creates wealth we produce in order to
trash and create wealth and we invest in
order to produce that is in essence what
capitalism is and it works it certainly
works better than anything else that's
been tried and it works more humanely
than anything else that's been tried yes
capitalism grows more complicated and
more ambitious as it evolved but its
principle to remain capitalism will
survive its current crisis it will be
tweaked and modified but it will not
collapse because nothing has ever been
found that can replace it all
do what it does or bring the advantage
in the benefits it brings it has brought
more to human achievement than any other
institution devised by humankind it
created wealth and on unprecedented
scale its enabled us to conquer disease
to conquer poverty malnutrition
starvation disease it's enabled us to
fund arts cultural activity education
social services capitalism is the most
benign thing people I've ever done and
that is why this motion cumbersome
ambitious as it is is also misconceived
and why I urge everyone to vote against
it
Thank You Matson our third and last
speaker for the motion that Karl Marx
was right
capitalism post 2008 is falling apart
under the weight of its own
contradictions is Frank for a day Frank
is professor of sociology at the
University of Kent his forthcoming book
is entitled moral Crusades in an age of
mistrust the Jimmy Savile scandal Frank
your time starts now
good evening comrades and and those of
you that still believe that the earth is
flat as well I think that if you look at
Karl Marx and you look at his writings
on a wide variety of subjects you'll
find that he had a very simple
interpretation of capitalism a very
compelling one and he basically said
that on paper in theory capitalism is a
wonderful idea it's a really brilliant
idea free trade free markets
individualism individual self
development sounds really brilliant said
in theory capsules was wonderful idea
the only trouble is is that doesn't work
in practice that's the only problem it
doesn't really work in practice and one
of the things that we find with
capitalism especially as it becomes more
and more mature is there's almost a a
desperate attempt to recast capitalism
in a way that is almost a caricature of
itself very often when you hear stories
of that Capitals say about their system
you almost imagine that they've been
reading Harry Potter and they're just
dying to write yet a lot of volume but
this time you know sort of with a a
capitalist happy ending and the stories
that you read in the newspapers are
really very interesting I don't know if
you picked up this story a couple of
weeks ago which would have really amused
Karl Marx was very small story was
really about the fact that our
government in its wisdom has decided to
privatize search-and-rescue operations
basically we now have a free market in
search and rescue it means that for
example if you stranded on
Mountain you know sort of in in Scotland
then you got a choice of which company
which company is going to come and
rescue you which basically in practice
means that on the one hand year one
company that's fronted by Prince Harry
you know you can have that brand as the
guy that kind of does the business or
alternatively maybe Prince Andrew will
front the other organization that will
do this and what you find is that
competition and the free market is
increasingly recast in this very silly
you know sort of kind of play-acting
form where everybody knows the dirty
secret which is that you know when it
comes to reality everything has been
sewn up sort of behind the scenes and
basically privatization in these
circumstances is really not so much
about the market but about a state
handout to a particular company it is
really the welfare state for the
capitalists it's their kind of
dependency culture that they often sort
of kind of go on about Marxist theory of
crisis is based on a simple idea it's by
the way it's a theory of crisis that he
actually shared with a lot of people who
weren't even Marxist who were often
friends of capitalism and if you read
David Ricardo if you read some of the
writings of system only the SIS Mundi if
you read even some what I Joseph
Schumpeter in the twentieth century they
all understood that capitalism has got
on any here in tendency towards this
integration and towards collapse that
the proposition is very simple
capitalism has a tendency to destroy the
very foundation on which it's built if
you look at the way that capitalism
develops it cannot tolerate a genuine
free market capitalism destroys the
values the traditions the religions on
which it was founded capitalism cannot
live with communities the communities
that gave rise in Scotland the Scottish
political economy are inconsistent with
what goes on before and then therefore
virtually everything virtually
everything that gave rise to capitalism
it's very foundation gradually gets
unravel
old to the process of accumulation and
therefore what we find is that with the
passing of time capitalism cannot
continue to accumulate on its own basis
it reaches its limits you see what Marx
was really objecting to wasn't
inequality and that's the way it's often
interpreted wasn't a fact that some
people were poor or some people were
rich basically his argument was very
simple was that capitalism cannot
systematically deliver the goods cannot
since this Matthew provide the living
conditions that we need for a civilized
society it's also another point Marx
points out to the destructive
consequences that are contained within
capitals and the tendencies towards this
integration towards collapse it makes
the point that as capitalism becomes
more and more mature it loses vitality
it can no longer simply rely on
individual capitalists to compete and
raise productivity and increase
production it makes the point that as
the falling as profit rates fall
increasingly capitalism destroys its own
defenses and is forced to look for new
institutional solutions to keep on going
it's what George called the coping
mechanisms continually looks for
different coping mechanisms to go on and
what he argues is at a certain point
this is the decisive inside the
sociological insight that Marx provides
at a certain point capitalism is forced
to seek refuge in institutions and in
customs that actually contradicts its
very nature and that's what we saw with
the search and rescue operation it
actually is forced to find refuge in
institutions that have got nothing to do
with the inner workings of capitalism it
emerges by the end of the 19th century
we find that free competition gives way
to monopolies an organized form of
competition because you simply cannot
tolerate real people genuinely competing
so you've got this big massive kind of
monopolies that carve up the market you
have a situation where it's not the
labor party it's not the left it's not
the Socialists it's the capitalist
themselves that go back the state
to intervene and state intervention
becomes the way of life of modern
capitalism in fact the capitalist class
is so addicted the state intervention
that it simply cannot do it at it I
don't know if you realize but even in
Britain today we got this so-called
neoliberal government when neoliberalism
comes from all that I know is that in
Britain in British society the state
accounts for something like almost half
of GDP anything between 45 to 47 percent
of GDP is actually a sort of carried out
through state expenditure and if you
find even in neoliberal United States
the state is a very active role in
propping of capitalism in all the key
areas all the important domains so we
have live credit I mean Robin talked
eloquently about quantitative easing you
know where is the free market there you
basically got these guys sitting around
in the Bank of England and say how much
how much should we give to these people
how big a handout does capitalism need
today
you know let's ease their life and you
kind of you know sort of circulate all
this money where's the company where the
free market where is the basic logic of
classical capitalism in this and in a
sense what we find is that capitalism
under these circumstances can only
continue by destroying its very
foundation at a certain point you cannot
simply increase state intervention
I mean Cameron is right if the state
increased expenditure we have a massive
disaster it's reaches limits
you cannot just simply you know sort of
throw more money at the problem at a
certain point you have what some of our
Joseph Schumpeter was a friend of
capitalism called disgust created
destructive creation and it was this
destructive creation that allows
capitalism to periodically survive my
argument is is that rather than you
sympathize term of destructive creation
we all get on the strand that of
creative destruction we have to
understand that the key challenge that
faces us in the 21st century is not to
sort of look and pretend that there is
no problem
understand how we manage the destruction
that our societies are experiencing and
will continue to experience there's no
doubt that the capitalist system will
need to restructure itself in a very
fundamental way and the only way that
they can do that is if it arose the
existing institutional framework within
which it's based so the question becomes
do we manage that destruction in a way
that doesn't benefit the mass of society
but only a small section of it or do we
have a grown up discussion a serious
grown-up discussion which genuinely
attempts to manage that destructive way
in a sense they will have a progressive
outcome thank you
thank you Frank our third and last
speaker against the motion is Judith
Shapiro Judith is a former revolutionary
Marxist she was previously part of the
team headed by Jeffrey Sachs advising
the Russian Ministry of Finance in
Moscow in 93 94 she's currently a tutor
in economics at the London School of
Economics
Judith your time starts now thank you I
have three basic propositions to put you
against the motion
first of all capitalism is not
collapsing let's have a reality check if
we simply look around the hall at this
packed auditorium of the vibrant middle
classes who are engaged in the Royal
Geographical Society which in Marx's day
was an elite dinner club and now has
10,000 fellows who belong to that middle
class and if we think about the fact
that there are grave threats to our
welfare but that this is very different
both from the 1930s if you are of my age
you have parents who told you over and
over about that it is both very
different from that and very different
from a system that I did see collapsing
the Soviet Union which did fall apart of
its own contradictions
some people may try to explain that that
was capitalism but some people will try
to explain anything so the the point is
that instead of the system collapsing of
its own contradictions it is as the
speakers who said they were for the
motion have said it is finding ways
which are not strictly free-market to
keep itself going and the notion of
capitalism as a model which can only be
a market is a model in our minds it is
not a reality capitalism as a word is
our model of modern society
the second point is as I've said that it
is indeed a grave crisis this is not
just another crisis it is not like the
oil shocks it is not like the dot-com
bubble it is not like the 1997 Asian
crisis this is a more or less epochal
crisis in the sense that we have to
resolve it in a very serious way in
which we change the way that modern
society works and what we're doing right
now is arguing about who is going to pay
for the debt that has been run up or in
complicated terms deleveraging and what
I want to put to you as the most single
important point I would like you to take
away tonight is that whatever is decided
in the technicalities and some of my
students have written in a little blue
booklet that you have most of you about
these technicalities however we do it
what we have to do is start reversing
the inverse burden law as I see it
forming in which the people most
responsible for the crisis are bearing
the least burden and those least
responsible because they're not being
exploited in the marxist sense they're
outside the system they are paying the
most and that is really looking at what
can happen with that it's a very fairly
simple story of what happened when we
had that sort of debt as a result both
of the 30s and of World War two that we
had moderate and mild inflation and we
had other means that go by the slightly
frightening term financial repression
which is a term many of you may not know
but trust me you will and it will no
longer seem a technical term
particularly if you figured out what
credit default swaps are and how they
differ from other sorts of initials
you've had to learn so and the euro is a
separate question that I leave aside
here because it was not economics
in command but politics that gave the
mistaken decision to have a single
currency for an area that can't hold it
and how you unscramble that omelette is
a separate question about which I think
there are intelligence squared debate
the third proposition the final one is
that there is nothing whatsoever in
Marxist economics that helps you to
understand it some of the finest writing
on the financial crisis I know is
Robbins in new left review starting in
fact in 2006 with a wonderful article
well before it was happening but I have
noticed I have not calculated it
statistically but we could put a student
to work at this that calling yourselves
a Marxist or not a Marxist gave you no
particular advantage in foreseeing it
Robin did not see I'm sure he would
agree the depth of it in fact Nouriel
Roubini who is definitely not a Marxist
did not because he's brilliant not
because of his analysis he may be both
of them may be correct but because he
lived in lives in New York City and
likes to have parties where bankers came
and he found out to his fright what was
happening there is another book I
recommend by someone who's never done
that sort of partying but he or he has
but in other people's money a Nick
Dunbar who was a physicist and who's
written a very wonderful very easily
readable book if you can't stand books
that don't have much economic analysis
and have no graphs and no equations
these make me edgy but they may make you
happy it's called The Devil's
derivatives each to his taste and the
point is that as Robin himself said I
think it was Robin the falling rate of
profit is probably wrong
Frank Feraud he basically made fun of
all Marxism and Tristram hunt as a
member of the Labour Party and an MP
really doesn't want to get up and say
that he believes Marxism is right he is
having a very good debating style which
he can do well and enjoying himself as I
hope you are too
but none of these people are Marxist
none of them believe that none of them
believe that capitalism is collapsing
and to vote that way just to scare the
idiots who are not doing policy right is
a mistake
that's why Nouriel Roubini first said
Marx was right he was fed up the way
that I don't know about you but I felt
when I saw what was happening about
Cyprus we nearly had a second Lehman
Brothers and everybody was doing their
own thing and all over the map and it
was terrifying but then they did
actually get some cold water dashed on
them and they did the right thing they
may not and that is why we need
education we need to know what we're
doing so that we ourselves can take more
of a role because another thing apart
from the growth of the middle classes so
that you have not been ground down but
the reverse and all over the world this
is happening including in China that it
is the the educated middle classes in
Shanghai and in a city where they did
not want a a poisonous cancer Factory
this is what I think is the forward
march in China and it will be also in
Russia it will be the educated middle
classes there and that is what we should
not feel sorry about
Tristram hunt I was disappointed to see
his article in the FT yesterday I hope
it was just a mood piece because I'm
sure he was asked because he is the
finest chronicler of the middle classes
so I have had a joke before in
january/february that I have five
opponents you know that I don't agree
with Madison for example on
laissez-faire but actually there are
five people six people counting me on
this panel who have argued to you to
support this to oppose this motion and
that's what I'm asking you to do to see
the sense behind the rhetoric and the
good jokes and to choose both common
sense and reality so that we can go
forward and we can find a solution where
the burdens are as little as possible it
will be unpleasant but it will not be
hell if we do it right thank you
very much
Thank You Judith ladies and gentlemen
you've heard six lucid expositions we're
now going to move on to questions I'd
invite you to give questions or
contributions as briefly in succinct way
as you can but before we do that I have
the results of the initial poll the
question you were asked as you came into
the Hall to remind you the motion in
front of you is Karl Marx was right
capitalism post 2008 is falling apart
under the weight of its own
contradictions the result so far is very
evenly balanced for the motion there are
two hundred and three votes against the
motion there are two hundred and
fourteen and don't knows number 197 so
it's roughly a third a third a third and
there is everything to play for will now
turn will now turn to questions and the
first question is from me
I'm going to ask very briefly if you
would ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen if you would each take a
question from me first the proposes of
the motion gentlemen George referred to
finance
as an endogenous source of systemic
instability and he added that with an
audience like this he didn't need to
elucidate the concept is he not running
that your analysis of the inherent
contradictions of capitalism is geared
specifically to something that is
outside the system it's the the failures
of of Finance capital any of you perhaps
you'd like to respond to that well I
think on the contrary I think that what
happens in the financial domain is a
reflection of the fundamental
contradiction that takes place within
the process of production I think that
the key that the most significant
development over the last 40 or 50 years
has not been the securitization of
economic life I think that's bad enough
it's been the inability of capitalism to
maintain rising productivity rises in
innovation it's its inner tendency
toward stagnation in the production
process which is the central core of the
capitalist system that's at issue the
financial system merely reflects that
because the problems of production are
displaced in through the credit
mechanism in a financial system and I
think that it was only finance that we
have a problem but precisely because the
productivity Rises has been pretty
stagnant to the 1960s I think all of you
would agree on that and that needs to be
explained how can a vibrant system fail
to maintain the momentum that it
achieved in the past okay sir please
welcome I want to pitch in just quickly
that I think really finance is too
important to valuable to be left in
private ownership and run on commercial
lines so really the essential point is
of course we can avoid this collapse
that's going on but the way to do it
would be to socialize finance and to
have not just one of course but a
variety a considerable variety of
publicly owned responsible accountable
institutions funds and financial
institutions ok the the opponents of the
motion Robin referred in his speech to
the madcap logic of fictitious capital
are you not making too big an exception
in your exposition of the resilience of
capitalism if you leave that out any of
you the point is that that Marx had the
strange fictitious capital but it's not
at the center of his analysis
unfortunately those people who have not
read Marx cannot today understand who's
right about what Marx meant if you want
to try to do it I have written some
notes on where you can look me it gave
me a headache Sunday to go back to that
stuff because Marx did not finish what
he was writing on the falling rate of
profit Robin could even say Marx was
right because Marx didn't
published chapter 13 of volume 3 angles
did it took him 11 years going over
Marx's notes to make sense of it and it
should have been like what we do in
conferences it should have had on the
front this is a preliminary draft please
do not read without do not cite without
the author's consent PS authors
residents Highgate Cemetery so but
angles didn't do that he felt his debt
to Marx to finish it and it is not
coherent it does not hang together and
it is not science as I understand it
because science as I understand it has
testable hypotheses and it is instead
ideology it may be good so that that's
my view on fictitious capital was one
idea that you can pluck and then you can
talk about it but it's not at the center
the productivity is but productivity is
I love the idea of people being able to
put on the Internet of what Trotsky said
mankind's productive forces stagnate and
then send it out posted to the web have
it on their iPad and say we haven't had
any growth capitalism is stagnating I've
read it myself
today online and I put it up on my blog
George quickly and then Tristram quickly
we go to go to the audience well ok then
quickly so I think that if you look
around the world and you know historical
development I mean our technological
achievements there I mean there is a
problem with productivity it's quite you
know it's quite cyclical but I mean
they're the standards of living that we
as we have achieved and that other
people all over the world aspire to I
mean are real and they are brought about
as a consequence of investment and of
you know the development of coping
mechanism finance is a problem and you
know I mean my understanding of Marx you
know that there isn't a huge amount of
financing Marx but he was quite you know
critical of what he called the
subordination of industrial capital to
finance capital it's basically what the
contemporary economic debate is about
you know banks doing all sorts of stupid
things with derivatives and there should
be
only to SMEs and so on so forth as
nobody would disagree with that and I
think unfortunately it is a problem as I
indicated before that Galbraith you know
quite correctly quipped which is that
every generation does it we all think
we're cleverer than our parents and our
grandparents we always make the same
mistakes but we carry on and that's life
Tristram Judith is right to take us back
to to the language of Marx and what Marx
assumed that he was himself writing
about and when Marx wrote about
capitalism he wrote about the kind of
capitalism which angles was working in
in Manchester in the 1850s and 1860s and
this was red in tooth and claw lace a
fair Nightwatchman state free-market
capitalism that is the capitalism which
is under discussion this evening what we
have this evening and what we have at
the moment in terms of our currency
could not economic models would from
Marx and Engels as perspective be a form
of collectivism as Frank said when
you've got the state operating at forty
five forty seven percent of GDP this is
not the kind of pure capitalism which
Marx was critiquing so in Marx's own
terms in Marx's own language the nature
of capitalism the contradictory forces
inherent in free-market capitalism on
his own terms is the issue we should
focus on this evil thank you Tristan
questions or contributions from the
floor I'll take three at once
first the lady in the middle there then
the gentleman there and there's a
question right at the back we could if
the ushers could take the microphones
there but madam first I have a question
for the speakers and speaking for the
motion and so you say that capitalism is
falling apart and but you haven't really
responded to and Madison's
argument that capitalism is the best
system that we've got so what would you
see as the alternative to capitalism I
should have asked you to say your name
first and if there is any Victoria
Victoria's question any of you well I
think that
there is no doubt about the fact that
capitalism is disintegrating and there's
no doubt about the fact that Marx's
analysis of this trend is absolutely
correct but Marx had two theories he had
a theory of collapse and he had a theory
of change and his theory of change was
that no system collapses by itself
unless there is an alternative unless
there are the social grouping prepared
to offer a different world and I would
argue that at the moment the big
challenge that faces us is not to revel
in the fact that capitalism is
collapsing that we got these big
problems that jutted outlined but to
work out a way of how we can manage what
is a very serious process of destruction
that we're going to be faced with the
next 10 15 years we haven't begun to see
what this depression is really like and
I think in the course of that we can
begin to develop our alternatives I
think the key thing is not to close our
minds to the future we've got to stop
living in the past I mean this is a
discussion about 19th century thinkers
but we really do need the 21st century
equivalent or people who are future
oriented and can begin to develop some
kind of alternative sorry to questions
once there's a gentleman here and a lady
I think a lady right at the back please
sit build already be really a question
for all of you the I think there's
almost unanimous agreement on the panel
that there is systemic failures if not
at the very least systemic problems and
therefore the key question is how do you
differentiate yourselves in terms of
what is the agency that will address
that systemic failure now Judith has
told us that correct agency is to have
cold water poured on you by an unelected
bureaucracy in Brussels I was wondering
what the other panelists thought the
agency is and a question at the back
carry Dingell from the education charity
world writing citizen TV worldwide
secret questions and firstly if do any
of this if the speakers for or against
the motion and do you believe in the
idea of a cannon in which case and a new
cannon for our times
would you have marks on it and which of
his writings might be on there and a
second quick question today's and
debates seem to be that happen in the
public sphere seem to demonstrate and
we've seen it here too that whether you
consider yourself left or right or
perhaps neither the state is the only
solution state intervention or welfarism
isn't there a better way to go
taking up neither of those and what are
your views on that okay I'll turn to the
opponents of the motion first to that
term that second contribution George
what writings of Marx do you think
should be on the Canon if any and any of
you what is the what is the agency that
you see as dealing with these remedying
these problems
well I the writings are very rich and
there's some wonderful quotes but I
would have to settle on the one that I
put in my main presentation which is the
bit about you know explaining the world
and the point is to change it of course
we've heard a lot of kind of political
rhetoric and explanations about what has
been what is what might be what should
be what shouldn't be the point is what
do we do about the situation which kind
of addresses your question about the
agency and your question as well about
what would you do otherwise I mean there
are clearly a lot of ways that in an
emergency such as we're in at the moment
where you know if the private sector
actually can't do something because it's
trying to behave in a certain way the
government has to compensate so you know
the insanity of what I've previously
called this deficit tension disorder is
the private sector is trying to say this
design is what exactly should do because
we actually run out too much debt and we
you know were seduced into buying things
that we shouldn't have been buying on
tick and now we have to kind of change
it so what kind of insanity is it for
the government to try to save at the
same time that the private sector is
trying to save so I don't think this is
a problem of capitalism
I think this is a problem about
political behavior and a lot of the
things that I think we've heard from our
opponents really are or is about but you
know just chronic and asinine political
behavior when we haven't even spoken
about the eurozone yet but anyway and
and that's really you know and that I
don't think is a systemic problem so I
think there are genuine things I mean I
accept the point that you know that the
the sort of 18th century capitalism is
clearly you know a different ant beast
from the kind of thing that we have
today and the government does have a big
role to play the state can facilitate
change mutualization can also facilitate
change too I mean we have a lot of
proposals which are being looked at for
example in the finance sector about how
you can mutual eyes financial services
and mutual and financial institutions
for kind of limited purpose banking I
mean not everybody's cup of tea but I
think you know we could take these kinds
of things quite seriously
Roman Marx's writings on the Paris
Commune certainly would deserve to be in
that canon and they dispel the myth that
he idolized the state and I really want
to respond to the question which said is
the only answer to the collapse the
tendency to collapse of capitalism which
is much graver in some parts of the
world than others but it's a reality
really globally is is there any way that
that the state intervention that can be
that is needed to stem that collapse is
there any way in which that can be saved
from bureaucrat ISM and a late ISM and
all the other problems that two mighty
states breed and I would argue that
there's a an idea there in Marx that the
state could be used to set up
organizations social funds for example
even cooperatives that just because
they're set up by the state because
they're publicly owned because they are
accountable to some group that doesn't
make them commercial it doesn't make
them capitalist and so really what I was
saying earlier it's it finances the
source of dynamism of
lism but it's failing us now so weary
need to rejuvenate with a state that
intervenes that sets up networks of
regional funds that get people working
again and I think that's desperately
needed and certainly that should include
small and medium business get them
working too but the the financial level
should be one of which democratic
criteria should apply it doesn't mean
the state should micro micromanage
everything in fact the state should get
out of a lot of things even that it does
now but they shouldn't be dumb handed
back to the failing capitalist model but
rather to some new model based on public
ownership and social cooperation
Tristram he wants to come come in on
this I just want to make a plea for
angles rather Mark's angles are the
condition of the working class in
England is is a superb text and when I
go and teach in schools at my
constituency in stoke-on-trent I give
them angles as account of going to Stoke
in the early 1840s and seeing the skin
peel off the fingers of children as
they're dipping the Dalton and the
Wedgwood we're into the chemicals which
made such beautiful products in there in
the Potteries and people are so
skeptical about the role of a Health and
Safety Executive after that I I would
also just say that Robin is exactly
right that Marx is great achievement was
the historicize capitalism was to
suggest that there are I there is that
there is a history to it which obviously
meant that there could be an end to it
but there are other forms of wealth
creation and when we look at the
co-operative model the mutual model the
Association is model even the family
business model these are more
interesting models of contemporaneous
capitalism thanks Tristram other
questions there's one right at the burka
gentleman with glasses there is a
gentleman right at the edge is there a
lady with a question there one two three
my question is sorry Mike Michael
Seifert my question is based partly on
what Robin said which is about Marty's
writing about the Paris Commune because
if you remember he said that men make
their own history but they don't do so
in conditions of their own choosing the
weight of past generations weighs like
an alt on the mind of the present
generation and what he meant by that was
that people can't just when they try to
think they're trying to break free from
the ideas that they've been heretic from
previous generations they find
themselves unable to do so and I'm
unable to face it but my question based
on that and based on Marx is historical
breath which starts with primitive
communism slavery just guess my question
is do the parallel think that capitalism
really is the highest form of social
development for humankind ok second
question there my name is eager I'm just
independent person it's it's a question
to to the members of the panel who are
voting against the motion and I'd love
to hear your views on the following do
we even leave at least in this in
Western Europe do we even leave in
Western Europe under capitalism is it
still capitalism can we call it
capitalism with the welfare state NHS
the state intervention and savings of
banking systems out the industries etc
etc where the state controls more than
50 percent in some countries like France
probably 70% of GDP can we still call it
capitalism that's my first question
again we leave it at 1 because that well
subsequently or now can we leave it at 1
please I do I do wish to be discourteous
but there are other questions ok I have
to explain the question right
thanks very much third question there
please thank you my name is Anne Cormac
I'm red in tooth and claw capitalist but
I have worked in my career in the
private sector as well as the public
sector my question to the panel is is it
not social democracy that is rather
failing us now in the sense that if you
look back at the causes of the crash I
would say it was actually the policies
implemented by both Bill Clinton and
also the previous prime minister in this
country actually allowing people who
were not capable of having the right
assets to be able to support borrowing
to go beyond what was feasible and
realistic and sensible for them to
borrow in those political moves lay the
seeds of the financial crash that have
actually happened and actually what
we're seeing around the place is a is a
broken social democratic model rather
than broken capitalism thanks very much
I'll turn to the opponents of the motion
first whichever of you wants to deal
with those three quite linked questions
is capitalism the highest form of Social
Development is it in Western Europe
indeed still capitalism and is it not
social democracy rather than capitalism
that's failing
Judith they are linked I think first of
all what do I think personally I think
my other panelists might disagree is
capitalism the highest form I hope not
but first of all we will need to be in a
situation where basically we have
abolished scarcity until we have that as
Trotsky brilliantly put it in the
revolution betrayed when you have
shortages queues form then a policeman
is called to keep order he never fails
to help himself first
so and I I think that I ignored the
problem when I chose to leap into
Marxism I knew already as a PhD in
economics who really believed in it also
that scarce
he was not going to be abolished easily
and with the new things we have seen
that Frank Ferrari thinks haven't
happened the productivity gains we have
so many more things we want all over the
world and we are not of course we could
want less I am happy I no longer want
plastic bags and I'm perfectly willing
to have a cloth bag I carry around and
doesn't have to have a label now but the
point is that we can want somewhat less
and maybe that's one of the things we
will get out of this long period of
deleveraging that we will learn to live
with less and with more leisure which we
didn't learn to do and we will have
there are some positive sides to it but
it will be not in our lifetimes and I
don't think in your children's lifetimes
not even the youngest people in the room
but someday I hope that many things will
be again as Trotsky said like a
well-mannered boardinghouse but I
personally as somebody who tends at a
well-known boarding house to take the
eggs I like first I have to be careful
and think yes first there have to be
enough eggs for everybody and that's the
I don't want my answer to the other is
do we even live under capitalism that is
a definitional question and I don't
think that it is relevant unless you are
a Marxist
I want to know if I want to know if it's
good or not first then we can work out
what it is and again social democracy no
I think social democracy has to decide
what it's doing that one of the problems
was that what I call social democracy
and when I came to next decided instead
to buy into the bubble and the boom and
it needs to find its way back and I hope
that people like Tristram will be part
of that because they went from the right
of me to the left of me to the right of
me in a whizz and many of you others may
have felt that I think there is a role
for government in the banks for example
I don't think I'll stop okay thanks to
Frank yes I think that you can blame
social democracy for many many bad
things but not for causing the problems
because the interesting thing is that no
matter what the government is whether
it's a Reagan led government or a
Christian Democratic led government in
Germany or a social democratic
government in France or in England we
see a similar pattern of relying more
and more on the credit mechanism with
see a situation where on the Reagan and
Thatcher you had the securitization of
the credit system on the Reagan in the
earlier period you have actually an
increase in state expenditure for a
certain Imperial time but still
expenditure not necessarily for welfare
payments but for armaments and for other
areas so I think it's important to
realize that there is no government in
the Western capitalist world that didn't
buy into this policy whose consequences
we're not paying for
I haven't sort of come across any of
that in the 70s and the 80s and the
early 90s I think that the really
important thing for us to remember here
is that the state can be used for all
kinds of reasons at the moment we have
the wrong balance state ought to be
providing resources for productive
investments like the way that labor did
for the Channel Tunnel in the 70s or the
way the defense have done with
high-speed trains
instead of doing that we're spending
state expenditure on transfer payments
in a way that has got no productive
operative what kind of consequences and
I think we do need to have a very
serious discussion of the balance
between private capital and the state
but at the moment all the political
parties are all avoiding George so we
just want to endorse you know pretty
much everything that Judith so I'm not
going to repeat it if it was eloquently
put the as aniconic sorry it's a bit
nerdy right but it's kind of what I do
but the standard text now about what do
we know about financial crises and why
do they happen and how do they behave
and how do you get over them is now a
book by two American economists by
called Raghavan Reinhard it's called
eight centuries of financial crises hey
sorry yeah eight centuries of financial
crises this time it's different
ie never is different and I think you
know Frank's point which is that it
didn't really matter what side of
political system it was whether it was
social democracy whether it was free
market whether it was you know whatever
it was I mean everybody suffered from
the same problem and the problem is well
the problem is just deregulation in my
opinion but actually the the idea about
that you could free up those animal
spirits in finance and expect human
behavior to control itself I mean it's a
human problem and it's something that is
you know it's a serial human problem
that goes back to the days of Rome and
even before it's not a uniquely
capitalistic problem is exaggerated by
capitalism because of the nature of it
but I think that the idea that you I
mean as I said before there are lots of
interesting ideas about you know whether
it's you know mutual societies or
cooperatives but you know handing kind
of having state backs the Chinese banks
were mentioned before the Chinese banks
are insolvent so you know and the only
way that they stay in business is
because of because they get continuously
bankrolled by the state that's not the
answer either okay quickly Robin I think
it is absolutely the answer I think one
of the marvelous things about the crisis
is we suddenly realize money which used
to be that great thing
that there was such a huge lack of that
actually governments can just country it
into existence and can endow other
institutions with it so instead of you
them using it to endow commercial banks
I would rather think the network of
social funds that would be a much more
creative way to use it and I think it
sort of provides some of the answer to
the question can we do better I think if
we look at the world there's too much
misery far too much and I think it'd be
wrong for Judith to imply that we can
sort of live with that and imagine the
market will spontaneously solve it the
market hasn't solved it so I think we
got to tackle it deliberately I'm just
back from Brazil and Ecuador and I can
say those countries have seen inequality
sharply reduced in the last ten years
because there are radical social
democratic governments that haven't
given up the ghost as sadly most
European Social Democrats have done and
I've taken really stern steps to spread
economic initiative to show that there
is such a thing as public
entrepreneurialism that can tackle
problems and get the economy moving
thanks Robin we're going to move now to
closing statements from each of the
speakers while they are giving their
closing statements the ushers will come
round with ballot boxes to remind you
you have a card with for or against
printed on it if you are in favor of the
motion please put the part of the card
in a ting for in the ballot box if you
are against but against if you're
undecided put the whole card into the
ballot box to remind you ladies and
gentlemen of the motion is Karl Marx was
right
capitalism post 2008 is falling apart
under the weight of its own
contradictions while you are voting if
you could be silent please while the
speakers deliver their closing remarks
in reverse order of having spoken so our
first speaker against the motion will be
doing it from the
from the platform our first speaker will
be Judith Shapiro just a couple of
minutes summing up your case Judith
please right well let me concentrate on
a misunderstanding which can only be
deliberate that two people have said
that I think it's all going to happen
spontaneously but I've made it very
clear that in fact the people like you
and me have to do something about it now
in fact the agency which we will
probably have to work is what Marx
called bourgeois democracy that means
political parties usually but they don't
have to be the existing political
parties I have slowly and reluctantly
come to the conclusion that there is no
other way out of the euro than to unwind
it so I think the new party being formed
in Germany to argue for that is probably
right and I think that the French system
needs such a party also because it came
before its time and it has been a
disaster and it threatens all of us
including us offshore islands so I think
that's very important when I ask you to
vote against the motion it doesn't mean
nothing is to be done it's the opposite
it's because something is to be done and
we have to do it now on the question of
the state and the market which are
definitely differences that as I
understand it divide us on each side of
the panel not between the two each
country and each time has a different
relationship the question is also which
state and which market East Asian states
have been able to do what my friends in
Eastern Europe knew would be a disaster
it may be that the Brazilian state is
doing it well I have not been there and
I am very suspicious always of reports
from faraway places I heard it about the
great Chilean pensions but I never
bought it when they privatized them but
I would like to know more about it
because some states can there was
enormous inequality in Latin America to
be reduced it was low hanging
reducing inequality in Western Europe is
going to be more difficult and then the
United States so I think it's very
important in asking you to vote against
the motion that you understand that we
are talking not about accepting the
status quo but rather seeing our side as
having more to say about what is to be
done and the other side of taking the
view that it's also terrible and maybe
even as a Tristram's first quote from
angle said oh goody
and then was disappointed that it was
not getting so terrible now I know none
of those speakers including Tristram
have that point of view they don't want
it to get worse but the point is there
are things to be done and we have to
decide what unlike Frank ferati I'm not
willing to wait 15 years while we work
out an alternative I'm not going to buy
into a movement again which tells me
that we'll think it up after we take
power and so therefore what we need to
do is to take the first steps decide
what are good policies decide what which
state can do it and do it well I know we
don't need the housing bubble that
George Osborne is planning for us but if
he really goes ahead I personally think
that you and me should buy some property
in the autumn to sell it in two years
when we have the crash just before the
crash I'm usually bad at that so but the
point is in asking you for your votes
what I am asking you to do my other
panelists may feel differently I am
asking you to say that the present
situation is not a good one but it is
the best we have and we need to play the
hand we have been dealt and let us hope
that we will play it well thank you very
much thanks Judy
for the motion your summing up comments
Frank the reason why I find Marx so
compelling in so many ways is because of
all the 19th century thinkers and
possibly 20th century ones as well he
was the one that was able to give the
most systematic expression of the values
of the Enlightenment I think that when
it comes to the basic values of freedom
and progress Marx put forward a very
robust future-oriented
view of possibilities he didn't just
talk about how bad things were he was
much more interested in pointing the way
forward to how great they could be and
his criticism of capitalism wasn't that
it was just a bad system that it wasn't
somehow working or right or or that it
was to sort of exploitative his real
criticism was that capitalism couldn't
deliver the goods actually held back
progress and the argument that really
motivated Marx in the argument that he
really developed the one that the one
that is I think very relevant for us was
a very simple one and it had to do with
history as Kristin was saying Marx his
stories as capitalism but what he also
did was to show that history is not
something that is out there history
isn't something that just happens beyond
our bags unlike many other defenders of
capitalism who see history as something
that happens to us somehow as Judy said
we have this hand that's given to us and
we got to deal with it he actually
believed that history was made by human
beings we don't have to be the objects
of history we don't have to be the
objects of history we could transform
the world around so we can be the makers
the subjects of history and it's his
theory of human subjectivity which was
the other side of his theory of
capitalism that we really need to think
about in the 21st century not because we
need to merely repeat what he had said
there's no point in merely finding
refuge in the past but because we too
need to begin to develop
an outlook that sees ourselves as the
makers of our circumstances rather
merely the passive warriors that we are
and I think in 21st century Britain when
passivity is so deeply institutionalized
when we really fail to take risks to
begin to take matters in our own hands
we're continually asking somebody else
to do stuff for us where we really have
become disempowered and become so
perilous that all that we can imagine is
that the state is the only institution
that could sort things out under those
circumstances rereading marks especially
for those of you the younger generation
will pay some very rich dividends
summarizing against the motion Madsen
Peary I don't think I don't think
capitalism is the highest product of
human social activity but I do think it
is a cooperative human social activity
if I were to put a book into the Canon
I'm very reluctant to do that because
once books are in the Canon people do
have a habit of slaughtering large
numbers of their fellow men and women in
the name of those books I would however
think this is unlikely to happen with
Adam Smith's Theory of Moral Sentiments
in that book he said that the most
salient human characteristic is our
ability to empathize with our fellow men
and women to think as they think see the
world from their point of view share
their joys and sorrows and at the heart
of capitalism is cooperation Marx
thought it was exploitative and
aggressive but it isn't it arises from
human nature from that empathy we have
with others when we trade we cooperate
the very first act of trade is human
beings cooperating it's not someone you
know aggressively seeking only their own
personal gain when someone invests they
put aside the spending power they could
be enjoying and instead they forego
present consumption and put that money
to use by someone who wants to create
goods and services that other
people will enjoy and use that money to
advantage to provide betterment for
other people
I think capitalism will survive because
inherently it goes with the grain of
human nature summarizing his case a big
button summarizing his case for the
motion is Robin Blackburn yeah I think
Madsen would find it interesting to dip
into Das Kapital because Marx plays
great tribute to cooperation in the
capitalist mode of production and he
says really it's private property that's
getting in the way of realization of
even higher levels and more effective
levels of of cooperation in the
Communist Manifesto he famously pays
tribute to capitalism and it's the fact
that it's unleashed enormous productive
powers I would put the manifesto on my
list for a cannon but I would say that
while it has great epoch-making ideas it
also has tiny little ideas that are
quite interesting - like one of them he
has a ten-point action program at the
back one of them is to have a
progressive income tax funnily enough in
the world of 1848 when it first appeared
there was no country that had a
progressive income tax so that was an
interesting idea that's been taken up
quite widely I just would like to
mention in that regard I was introduced
by the president correa
in Ecuador to the chief of his tax
collection unit who as it happened is a
Ecuadorian man called Carlos Marx
and the thing that Carlos Marx told me
is that he'd had the revolutionary idea
for Ecuador not of raising taxes he said
he thought that they were just about at
the right level but of actually getting
people to pay their taxes and he'd
actually managed to double the country's
tax revenue by this novel procedure so I
would just conclude I I think we've got
to learn to innovate in Social Affairs
as well as in technology and that one of
the innovations would be public
entrepreneurship of seeing things that
there's a crying need for something to
be done about and democratically
deciding to commit resources to that and
then let the people involved get on with
it without further meddling occasional
accounting but not micromanagement
and concluding his case against the
motion
George Magnus strangely I wasn't
mentioned this but Robin just kind of
spurred me to think about something that
there is I think fair game because we've
heard a little bit of discussion this
evening about a lot of discussion about
finance and about money and about QE and
all that malarkey and we have this kind
of idea that we have to produce all this
QE actually the money doesn't go
anywhere except inside the banking
system so you know the problem about it
is that we have this fixation that we
can only use quantitative easing and use
this tool to stimulate what we think
will stimulate private spending and
private lending and actually clearly
it's not working because private sector
wants to say it's going through that
kind of a phase why we have this
obsession that we can't use the same
tool to basically take debt effectively
straight off the government without
increasing public debt and actually
putting 50 billion pounds into the banks
to capitalize them and get them to lend
again which is kind of what we want or
why we can't use you know a certain
amount of money to basically achieve
what the coming governor of the Bank of
England Mark Carney is called as escape
velocity which is you know builds some
stuff you know get put people to work
and then you know the private sector
will take care of itself I think these
things will you know could happen very
easily but I want to kind of conclude
really by just pointing out you know
what again one of my gurus John Maynard
Keynes basically identified as the
central economic problem which was to
combine economic efficiency social
justice and individual liberty and I
think that's been an evolving problem
over the last 200 years or so and will
be for the next 150 200 years and we are
going to make mistakes from time to time
as we have done in their 2000s to
catastrophic effect we know and but you
know I'm pretty sure we'll sort it out
and you know there are as I try to
allude coping mechanisms which will
nurture and create to help us do this
but it will take time and it's a very
painful period thanks George
and for his final comments in favor of
the motion Tristram hunt well lady
general you have all voted now and I
want to pay tribute to those of you who
are on the right side of history we've
made the right decision tonight to the
others we've given you a hint of a
reading list it's a very good biography
of angles available if you want to
pursue that further I would also tell
you that socialism is fun don't be
worried embrace it
one of angles is main concerns when he
was living in Manchester in the 1850s
was how to get the ingredients for
lobster salad
he got them in the end listen if you
were part of a collective loss of 20
billion pounds on a collective rice farm
you would probably begin to have some
questions about the viability of Maoist
socialism you are currently part in the
UK of a 20 billion collective loss on
our shareholder driven laissez-faire
capitalist banking structure that is the
loss you're facing at the moment so for
those of you who said things aren't
working out quite as well as we hoped
for those of you who voted to say that
Karl Marx might have a point you are on
the right side of the analysis because
what we want ultimately to end up with
is is a more sensible system of wealth
creation which is where this discussion
have been heading at the end we want
more producers and less predators we
want more cooperatives and we want less
collateral debt obligations and what we
want to do to go back to George's
musings around a high Gate Park and
always remember that Karl Marx is buried
in the shadow of a mental asylum is to
stop the interpretation and to try to
start to change the world thank you
thanks very much Tristram and the final
act of the evening Falls to me to read
out the results of the vote to remind
you the motion for the last time Karl
Marx was right capitalism post 2008 is
falling apart under the weight of its
own contradictions before the debate
those in favor of the motion numbered
203 those against were 214 and don't
knows were 197 many of those don't knows
have now made up their minds and the
result at the end of the debate for the
motion 217 against the motion 316 and
don't knows 37 so my thanks to
intelligence squared for hosting the
debate and to the speakers thank you
very much traitors in general